le Québec peut-il interdire la culture
du cannabis à domicile voici la question
soumise à la Cour suprême du Canada
c'est un grand changement en 2018 avec
la décriminalisation
Ottawa a permis au Canadien de cultiver
jusqu'à 4 plans de cannabis à la maison
mais le Québec a adopté une approche
plus restrictive l'interdiction de
cultiver du cannabis à des fins
personnelles absolument un Québécois
contestait cette interdiction qui allait
selon lui à l'encontre de la loi
fédérale des arguments qui n'ont pas
convaincu les juges dans une décision
unanime la Cour suprême affirme que les
provinces ont le droit d'agir ainsi afin
de protéger la santé et la sécurité du
public particulièrement celle des jeunes
les provinces ont le droit de
d'encadrer la vente de la
commercialisation du cannabis de manière
à créer ce que le Québec fait un
monopole d'État autrement dit le Québec
peut interdire la culture du cannabis à
domicile pour diriger les consommateurs
vers la sqdc ou la qualité des et
contrôlé le ministre de la justice sont
réjouis il écrit nous sommes satisfaits
du jugement de la Cour suprême
confirmant la pleine capacité d'agir du
Québec en la matière il y a certaines
éléments de déception mais écoutez c'est
on n'a pas le choix c'est la décision du
plus haut tribunal donc l'avocat du
plaignant déplore quant à lui que le
Québec soit la province la plus
restrictive au pays je pense que le
Québec malheureusement il l'enfant
pauvre en matière de cannabis et très
conservateur sur cette question là faire
pousser des plans à des fins personnels
et permis partout au Canada sauf au
Québec et au Manitoba et la pratique n'a
pas posé problème jusqu'ici selon
l'industrie
des éléments préoccupants dans les
provinces autres que le québecobar ou
c'est permis la loi québécoise malgré
tout et donc maintenu ce qui cultivent
du cannabis à la maison s'exposent à des
amendes allant de 250 à 750 dollars ici
Sébastien Desrosiers Radio-Canada Québec